first off start with the dough tip 500
grams of strong bread flour into a
mixing bowl
and add 20 grams of semolina
that gives the vacation it's sort of
rustic charm
now there's one thing for catching needs
it's really good seasoning
you can't season bread after it's baked
so it's got to go in right at the very
beginning
sprinkling 15 grams of dried yeast take
some warm water
and 50 ml of olive oil top of that water
that gives it this really nice silky
rich texture
make a little well mix up that yeast
water
and oil in start off with your fingers
keep your fingers nice and open it's
like a little sort of whisk
going in there i'm looking for a really
nice sort of relaxed
dough
now let's just start to come together
touch more water
with the oil in there give a little
swirl and then again
the secret is to sort of knead it gently
don't overwork it it's a sort of
easy bread to make a nice one to start
off with when you're making bread for
the first time
basically kneading means just knit it
together just hanging
lightly flour your board and let's just
knead that focaccia
into a nice smooth dough make sure you
don't over add
too much flour otherwise it sort of
dries out the dough
something quite magical about making
bread you can switch off
and lose yourself my first job for three
mission star establishment
was a baker i was 22 years of age i used
to start at midnight
i was under such a tight schedule one
o'clock
white bread then two o'clock brown bread
three o'clock sourdough
four o'clock cheese bread five o'clock
prove bake
six o'clock crack them open and taste
it was amazing beautiful
yeah looks stunning it hasn't even risen
yet
leave your dough to rise in a warm place
until it's doubled in size
we call this proving
that beautiful a lot of chefs sort of
need it for the second time but i'm
looking for a really nice light
aerated focaccia take a tray
a touch of olive oil in there season it
at the bottom
really important that's the exciting
thing about focaccia you've got that
really nice sort of salty top
and salty bottom and just with a touch
of olive oil
on your hands gently push that in and
almost massage it
into the corners it's possible to put
sort of olives and
tomatoes and garlic through the dough
but it never really
allows the dough to sort of bake
properly when you put so much
ingredients in
i'm going to stick mine on top use your
finger and sort of just push them in
salt on top some pepper on top as well
i want some nice fresh amazing rosemary
just hold the stalk
and just pull off and then just sprinkle
down
generous in the rosemary really
important to have that nice
fragrance on top of the focaccia finish
it off before it goes in
with a little drizzle of olive oil so it
almost sinks in those little pockets of
flavor olive tomato rosemary and olive
oil
into the oven bake your focaccia at 200
degrees for 30 to 35 minutes
[Music]
smells delicious
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
you can hear how crispy that is you
can't beat
a nice warm fresh slice of home-cooked
focaccia
it's rustic charming and it's the
perfect way
to start baking making homemade for
catcher
it's so addictive
one nicely skinned salmon just like a
perfect snakeskin
because sliders are bite-sized burgers
designed to go in small buns you don't
want to make them too big